I was reminiscing with Mark Grace last
night former Cubs Diamondbacks all-star
first baseman and reflecting back on the
1998 home run chase mark of course
didn't hit home runs but he had a great
seat for by choice right Gracie you
didn't hit home runs back then hey Sammy
combined for 83 home boys yeah he had 66
and I had seven alright what do you if I
say 1998 and that home run chase like
what's one thing that you remember the
most about that oh my goodness can I
give you a can I give you three things
should I remember about it because you
know 98 was was obviously the it was a
big deal Sammy and McGwire and the home
run is excitement over that and every
single one of their abies was was going
on ESPN and and there was a big deal but
also from me
that year the the rookie emergence of
Kerry Wood was a huge deal in Chicago
and in baseball you know he had struck
out 20 didn't him and I think Bob felt
are the only two to ever strike out
their age and think about that yeah and
so so doctor obviously a big deal for me
and Chicago and the Cubs was was the
postseason you know we were in
contention all year we ended up winning
a one-game playoff against the San
Francisco Giants to to go and meet the
Braves and we've lost the brazen in the
next series but they on three of the
biggest stories in baseball were going
on in Chicago the home run chase Kerry
Wood and his Ruby here campaign and then
the Cubs being in the postseason that
day with Kerry Wood I think it's the
greatest performance I've ever seen
because I that was what Kerry Woods
fourth or fifth start he's facing the
Astros they had a really good hitting
lineup and a great hitting lineup yes
and I saw a guy throw a frisbee that day
and not many pitchers can throw a
frisbee
Kerry Wood threw a frisbee that day and
I don't think they had any chiming
you're there
first-base I don't know what you
remember about that but those were grown
men who had no chance against Kerry Wood
to Hall of Famers in bag long vision
more great hitters in Derrick Bell
Moises Alou
you know they had they had a great
lineup so that said I remember I just
people you know after about the second
inning I was just like you know what I
can go out there and put my glove on my
head and because because he's got these
guys are not you guys aren't getting the
ball they're not going to hit the ball
if they found if they found one off we
were like man and scary all right that
was well I think the metrics you know
the the propellerheads have have said
that that is the greatest game ever
pitched in the modern era you know I
mean you guys don't want not metrics
than I do so I'm not hard with it the
home run chase with I don't know if
Maguire enjoyed it but you around Sammy
everyday and it felt like Sammy was
starting to eat this up he was enjoying
it a lot more than Mark McGwire McGwire
said he felt all this pressure but what
was what was Sammy like during that that
year now he was uh he was loved Heba
loving every second of it and and once
again it was it was not only was it him
but it was also our team so we were all
in because we were we were winning games
and and going for the postseason Sammy
was going for the postseason and also
going for the home run record and so it
was he loved every second of it and and
and we we all we all got into it I mean
it was a it was a it was a big deal it
was a really big deal but you're right
Sammy was the one always with a smile on
his face it seemed like Mac whom I've
known you know since college he was at
USC when I was at San Diego State and it
just and he's a good dude and he's and
he's a fun-loving guy but yeah he did he
did have a bit of a sour puss attitude
about it I would say yeah I just look
back on that and I I remember when
McGwire broke the record Roger Maris's
record and you were at first base and
you congratulated him which I think
opened the door for all of your
teammates in the infield to congratulate
him did you catch any grief for
congratulating McGwire after he hung up
there was a there was a few people you
know locals diehard Chicago Cup fever
you know they thought it was BS on my
part to do it but I just I just
hearkened back when when I was a kid and
I think we all people our age Danah all
remember when a Hank Aaron broke Babe
Ruth's record 7:15 I remember when he
was running the bases I saw davey lopes
shake his hand after he hit the home run
ha ha how about him and I and I that's
then I thought you know what that's all
right you know and then when Mac didn't
um it wasn't so much about you know
showing up steep tracks or showing up
anybody ah we just witnessed history man
you know that nobody else had ever done
what Mac did at that time yeah that was
pretty cool to do congratulations
but and if you know it's yeah yeah if
you didn't like it tough that's word you
know he's a Mark Grace former cub
diamond bangles to our first baseman but
as great as McGwire and Sosa were that
year Barry Bonds was at a different
level than we've ever seen in the
history of the sport and so you're at
first base when bonds is up you're
probably not worried about a liner to
first it felt like if Bonds was swinging
he was trying to hit a home run every
single time he rarely had a ground ball
that's for sure he was he he was a pull
you know here's a pull hitter but and
but I wasn't too worried about him you
know Charlie Brown and me with a line
drive because they were they were
usually going over into the drink and I
McCovey Cove but yeah the thing was the
thing with bonds was you know the year
that he hit 73 I think was it was that
the total 73 yeah but the year he hit 73
he was in personally watched so many
times so many times I know pack and
salsa didn't get intentionally walking
near as much as
as Barry did and Barry still so so the
bottom line you know those last you know
couple years for Barry when he was
hitting all the home runs if you didn't
walk him he hit a home run he didn't hit
a double if you pitch to him if the
catcher got down his crouch behind the
plate he had home run that was what he
did so basically I put up I put my glove
on my head it wasn't coming to me is so
so ever gonna be welcome back by the
Cubs that's a great question I don't
really know that whole scenario I was
not in Chicago when the divorce happened
I had left a couple of years earlier so
I don't know exactly what went on in the
clubhouse and what went on I know he got
I know he got caught with cork in his
bat and then I know he there was left
early on the last game last game of the
season he didn't didn't come back I
don't know exactly what happened but you
know I think I think you know he'll they
welcome me back why wouldn't they
welcome back Sammy yeah you don't do
anything wrong thank you Dan
thank you so much you've always had my
back and I'm getting a little misty I
know he said that man but but no when I
left it wasn't in under the greatest of
circumstances they have their side of
the story I have my side of the story
and there's always a third side story so
that's it yeah it was when sandy left
there was I think there was a little
more tension as far as how how he
behaved and how how things were I wish I
wish I had a better answer because I
wasn't there I was busy out in Arizona
you know finishing up my career but I
don't really know other than that but I
would say you know for the Cubs sake and
for Sammy's sake I think you know
welcoming welcoming him back would
probably make a lot of fans Cubs fans
happy yeah but it's kind of hypocritical
that the Cubs celebrated those sold-out
crowds because you know in large part or
certainly a pretty good share
sammy sosa a lot of merchandise there
and then now it feels like they're
distancing themselves from a PE d user
so I don't I don't know if in its new
ownership there but I don't know if that
factors in it all Gracie
yeah that's a that's a great point and
you know there's there's a lot of PE d
users that that are not banished from
their teams you know that like you said
you know all the merchandise all the
crowds that were there to see he said
because I remember when the year that
Sammy McGwire I remember if it was like
the 7th or 8th inning and I hid behind
Sammy and Sammy would his last going to
be his last at-bat and and he's uh he'd
either hit a homer or he'd hit a single
read making out or whatever he did it
right after his that bat was over with
more than half the crowd would would
would head to the exits and now hitting
Mark Grace I'm just here to punch a
bunch of how are you not tempted to use
steroids ah I'm gonna give you the
honest answer Dan ok I was a single man
in Chicago and that stuff is bad for
your get up and go if you know what I
mean so so I wanted to continue to have
the ability to get up and go so that's a
big reason second of all I don't think
myself my swing was conducive I wasn't a
fly ball hitter I was a hit line drives
and ground balls for the most part if I
if I elevated the line drive it would it
would go out of the ballpark so I just
don't think I was never interested in it
and I'm glad I didn't because now
looking back on my career my numbers
were my numbers not a syringe numbers
they were my numbers and I'm proud of
that twenty four hundred hits three
hundred batting average all right I told
the story about Randy Johnson the other
day on the air when you were in Arizona
and you were playing the Cubs you were
in Chicago and I go to see you in the
locker room you and Luis Gonzalez and
Randy Johnson's pitching that day and
you guys convinced me to go say hello to
Randy Johnson that didn't know well on
gameday like you don't I wouldn't talk
to him when he wasn't pitching and
knowing what I know now but you guys go
say hello to unit man he'd loved it you
know I walked down there
and he just stared at me we were trying
to anything we could to try to get it in
center bothering herself dominated us
and we had no chance but you know the
like somebody asked me hey and to
compare to the two best pictures of at
least you know you got a throw
Roger Clemens in there too but two of
the best pictures of our era Randy Randy
Johnson and Greg Maddux and I my god
that's interesting I said well do you
remember it like there was there was two
guys that you absolutely hated in high
school you you hated the boys wait for
you in the in the bathroom steal your
lunch money you hated that guy well that
was Randy Johnson on the mound Randy was
a big bully that would steal your lunch
money and then Greg Maddux he was like
he was like the valedictorian but got a
hundred on every test and set the curve
not a hundred and you hated that guy
town yeah that was Greg Mac so so the
two guys you hated like in high school
but one was the bully reason and the
other one was the valedictorian reason I
I know that we've told this story we and
we add Maddux on when he told this story
when he got it a little more excited on
the mound then you wouldn't normally
expect somebody to get excited his get
up and go so you're at first base and
when do you notice that Greg Maddux is
he went from 6 o'clock to midnight
well he he threw a pitch I remember he
was kind of he was kind of favoring like
you know if a pitcher or any player kind
of kind of pulls a groin or or you know
they start walking strange so man
there's our there's our bread-and-butter
guy out there are so young kind of like
like you okay dude and he's like Gracie
just stand in front now am i okay I'm
like what's going on and he he told me
basically how excited he was to be
pitching that day and I told him I told
him I said well you just loved and he
talked and he told the wrong guy to
because you know I'm not going to keep
that to myself that's a story that had
to be shared
so needless to say he went he went on to
to bigger and if as you could say after
that that was it's just it's just one
more it's just one more thing that you
know you you can't believe these things
actually happened in in the game but
they did yes it's amazing
you went through a lockout and a strike
I believe and here we are with toying
with 50 games we're gonna have baseball
well I think they better they better
because you know this is unprecedented
you know coronavirus stuff and it's just
decimated not a baseball decimated
sports you know I never realized how
much I loved watching sports on TV until
they were all taken away geez I was
watching Matt Williams and managed
Korean baseball for all the lounges so
so and I'm sorry but he watched those
games and just realized man Major League
Baseball needs to come back and and
that's that yeah I went through I went
through to I was locked out one time
when I went on strike one time and you
know the replacement players and all
that I was a disaster and you know all
that but I just recall both times that I
went on strike the court of public
piñon no matter no matter what is said
and no matter what is done owners are
the bad guys no the players are the bad
guys you know they're gonna point
fingers at each other but the court of
public opinion down I think you'll agree
with me is always always against the
players 90% of the fans are blame the
players anytime there's a work stoppage
and I think Tony Clark and his crew I
think they understand that but they need
to really understand it because this is
a this is an important one don't you
think yeah yeah
because attendance has been dropping and
you know fans or they move on eventually
when they don't feel like a league of
sport invest in them or cares about them
you know after a while and you know that
you got the oldest target demo in all
the sports is your baseball fan and you
know you're flirting with a whole
generation that you're just moving on
past and it's unfortunate really is well
yeah and you know the game was losing
fans because the the beauty of the game
especially on the offensive end is is
going away you know it's all launch
angle it's all it's all you know this
launch angle and spin rate and and all
these all these things have led to
record not record-breaking record
shattering
homeruns and record shattering
strikeouts so that kind of odd you know
the beauty of the hit-and-run or the
suicide squeeze or even is it just are
the stolen base it's like literally you
know a handful of guys that steal bases
anymore so that that part of the game is
gone and and I think a lot of a lot of
fans especially the older fans they miss
the beauty of the baseball they are
coming a little bored with you know the
all-or-nothing thing that baseball has
become offense good to visit with you
and stay in touch oh it's a pleasure my
friend have a great rest of your day
tell the boys I said hello that's Gracie
Mark Grace a former cub great
Diamondback great and won a World Series
there